[موسيقى]
حركه الارض حول نفسها ينتج عنها شروق
وغروب الشمس وهو يعبر عن اليوم وحركه
القمر حول الارض ينتج عنها اشكال القمر
ابدار تربيع واهلال وهو يعبر عن الشهر
وحركه الارض حول الشمس ينتج عنها الفصول
الاربعه صيف وشتاء وخريف وربيع وهو يعبر
عن العام وهذه الحركات الثلاث تعبر عن
التاريخ والزمان وهي الفترات الزمانيه
القابله للقياس وتعيد سيرتها الاولى كما
بدات والدنيا ماشيه سواء حزنت او فرحت او
فكرت تفكير سلبي او ايجابي والعامه يقولون
الكاين صاير والهم
زياده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومرور الوقت مرتبط بالاحساس النفسي
فالانسان الحزين يمر عليه الوقت بتباطؤ
قاتل والانسان السعيد يمر عليها الوقت مثل
البرق ورمضان واقع بين اطول واقصر شهور
السنه اللي شعبان وشهر شوال ففي شهر شعبان
يمر علينا الوقت بسرعه ولهذا العامه
يسمونه بل قصير ليش لاننا نشتاق لرؤيه
رمضان والزمن يمر بسرعه لانها من الفترات
السعيده وفي شهر شوال يتباطى الوقت لك
لاننا نودع شيئا ثمينا عندنا انه شهر
رمضان ولهذا يتباطا فيه الوقت الا ايها
الليل الطويل الانجلي بصبح وما الاصلاح
منك
بامثالك
[موسيقى]